Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr is the Monday morning podcast for Monday over
June 8th,
2016 what's going on when June two limos,
Yuma bell gill a shiver dre says what's on cat team who play?
I can't fucking say it anymore,
man.
I'm ready to come home.
I've had a great time over here.
Uh,
and uh,
you know,
but no matter how much of a good time you haven't,
at some point you miss you stuff.
You want to go home and see your dog,
you know,
you'd just like to fucking speak your own lane.
I'm so fucking sick of trying to speak this shit over here.
I'm having a great time.
My French is better than it's ever been.
Uh,
but I am fucking,
you know,
the memes shows seafood play.
That means more of the same.
If you ever in a bar and you finally get your fucking out whatever you wanted,
you know what I mean?
You know?
Juva Dre,
my fucking Jack Daniels on ice or whatever,
when she get that shit out and they know what the fuck you saying when they come
back,
you know,
and they're like,
we miss you.
It was a little bit of a disability.
You just point your glass,
you go the memes shows CBRE play and they go and they walk away and they come
back and magically they give you another fucking uh,
and one of the glass or whatever the fuck you just ordered.
And um,
I also found out over here then I like green beans,
green beans.
It's like,
oh,
I whatever,
you know,
I forget what they call him over here.
Arrow.
God,
I can't even remember.
I fucking look at it and I can read it and I not to say,
you know,
uh,
Java Dre,
a salad area,
God spared bat,
whatever the fuck you say.
Right?
And all it is is green beans is a little bit of fucking this mustard dressing
they put on him and I got to tell you,
it's out of this fucking world.
So much shit over here that I don't like over in the states is really out of
this world over here.
And um,
and I've been eating like a fucking animal over here and I haven't really been
putting on the weight that I put on when I'm in the states because I don't know
what the fuck they do.
Even like the,
uh,
the chicken,
Tulay a
roti superbly.
See what Blair?
Right fucking rotisserie chicken over here.
I swear to God our chicken over there is on steroids.
I don't know what's going,
I don't know what the deal is.
Like we bought a full chicken and you know,
I'm not gonna lie to you.
I was a little buzzed and I can carve a chicken or a Turkey,
like nobody's fucking business.
Why?
Because I'm some sort of chef.
No,
cause I watched a youtube video that broke it down.
So I'm sitting there and looking at this chicken and like I said,
I was a couple of drinks and I couldn't
figure out where the breast meat was.
Okay.
I couldn't tell really the top from the bottom of the thing because I'm so used
to our Mark McGuire roid it up fucking chickens that you know,
it's puffing up like it's going to Gold's fucking over.
Right.
And uh,
yeah,
it's just,
it's like Dick Chicken over here looks like a fitness model right where ours
looks like.
Who's that guy in the Astros?
It played third base that never got busted for fucking looking like,
uh,
the same body type is Robert Newhouse.
That's what I'm chicken looks like.
And um,
okay.
Yeah,
the green beans are smaller and they're way more tastier.
And I was over here going,
I fucking love green beans.
I didn't know that.
I think that the ones we have over where we're at,
they shit and I'm not trashing America.
I'm not being one of these concept goes to another country and go,
oh my God,
everything they have over here,
it's fucking wonderful.
I'm not saying that,
let's say in that at all.
I'm just saying that,
uh,
yeah,
I'm actually talking to the rest of the world that makes fun of how fucking fat
Americans are.
Like date.
I Dunno.
I Dunno what happened,
but there's,
there's something wrong with that goddamn food.
Um,
having said that though,
I would rather look at a fat American then affect European because at least in
American it's some point in his life,
did a fucking pushup and as some sort of a,
some sort of shoulders in some arms and a little bit of jest on them.
These fucking fatties over here,
they're just,
they're like a,
they get like chick bodies.
Like they never did a pull up in their life or anything and then they just get
fat and then they keep wearing the tight tee shirt,
you know?
Okay.
Like those gay guys do.
The gay guys who West Hollywood,
I don't give a fuck what shape they're in.
They wear it tight shelf.
But the gay dudes in America at least,
at least have the decency dig,
still trying that go into the gym.
So they don't look that bad.
At least they got the guts,
some fucking guns on them.
You know,
they got some packs,
right.
Some older guy packs.
I mean I should talk right now.
That's what I look like.
I look like a fucking Tuesday afternoon stripper right now with my shirt off.
You know,
you could see how at one point maybe I used to dance on Saturday night,
but now I've had like two or three fucking kids out of wedlock too.
So it was a hard two or three,
right?
No fuckin alimony.
Even if I know who the fuck and father is,
he doesn't have any money.
You can't get blood from the stone.
That dude sitting in jail,
you know,
it's stupid.
He should be out driving a truck somewhere.
Right?
Why the fuck isn't my laptop charging?
Yeah.
That's another thing I'm fucking sick of.
I'm sick of this fucking whack of American electricity.
Have A,
Ah,
I'm just a fucking grouchy cut right now.
Um,
but having said all that,
you know,
we're still having a great time over here.
I'm just a,
you don't even realize,
I haven't really been vacationing over here as much as I bet on like a seven day
bender.
It's like,
I gotta get,
I gotta stop.
Like at some point,
we finally just said like,
you know,
when we live at home,
we don't go out to a bar every night.
You just,
when you're on vacation,
you feel like,
oh,
I got to do something every night.
And one of those things you could do is actually relax and get a good night's
sleep,
you know,
and you would think,
being a cat,
those says how the fuck you say it kept to a cease,
I just did a youtube thing.
I said 16 first,
soon to be and a cat toy as Catera cata sets.
That's where it'd be on,
on Wednesday and Thursday.
Mcity as your Dick.
I don't fucking,
I just woke up.
Fuck you.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
you'd think being almost 47 years old that I would have learned that by now,
but I didn't,
you know,
and there's probably a lot of you looking down on me,
like I'm some sort of fucking asshole.
But now you never really learned that lesson either.
What happened to you is you got married and you had a fucking kid.
And from what I've heard from parents whose kids don't give a fuck about a
hangover.
So just because you don't want to deal with your kid,
you stopped drinking or maybe you love the thing,
right to the point where you don't want to be the drunk mom or dad.
But I swear to God,
you know,
parents,
anytime they get a chance for the most part,
they steal away a couple of minutes,
the grandparents come over and take the kids.
They're immediately in the liquor cabinet.
Right.
All right,
well there you go.
Sorry.
You know what?
This really is,
is me just feeling like I'm drinking too much.
So instead I got a fucking lash shouted at.
People never really said anything to me.
Maybe it just sitting there with a kid going,
hey bill,
you know,
just kind of enjoying the podcast.
There's no reason for you to be a cunt to me cause yeah,
you're a freckled Boosie back.
And you know what?
I'll take that.
I will take that.
You know what?
You're right.
And I apologize.
You see that trying to be more mature.
Um,
so anyways,
uh,
also,
you know what the thing is,
is yesterday I went to the French Open and that was like the big thing that I
wanted to do.
So I think mentally I kind of checked out like,
God,
I'm done.
I had the coolest Saul's.
I had the Baguettes,
I sat in the cafes and I fucking did whatever the fuck I did.
I went to the French Open,
you know,
I took my lady out on her birthday,
I got her a really nice gift.
I feel like I'm done like roll credits and uh,
I still got two days here before I fly back to three days for fly back.
And um,
but I don't want this,
this,
this is the calm before the storm,
you know,
rather than being depressed then it's almost over.
I'm actually kind of excited cause I'm ready to go back,
but somewhere around two in the afternoon today it's going to hit me like,
oh fuck,
you know,
I only got another two and a half days here and then the drink is going to start
all over again.
And there is something about the fact that Jim Morrison died in this town,
that you really feel like a pussy if you just fucking go home.
So when I'm saying to you is,
I'm going to be fucking hammered until about Wednesday.
[inaudible]
um,
okay.
So this is the Monday morning podcast.
Uh,
you know what I did the other night before I went to the,
the French Open,
I got my NHL feed to work and I watched game to have a Tampa Bay versus Chicago
and um,
what a fucking game,
what a series.
I'm so psyched that I actually was able to see that because I'm fucking missing
the calves Sacramento series,
as I called it last week.
The calves,
uh,
golden state series.
Um,
it looks like a classic.
I don't think the first game went into overtime,
but I know that the,
uh,
the uh,
warriors one by two and then last night the Cavaliers won by two and overtime.
And I just saw the look on the Cavaliers faces,
like,
you know,
after they had won it,
like it was that combination of,
of happiness and anger lay just like,
all right,
these guys are fucking dialed in.
This is going to be a hell of a series.
And I did see something funny on the NBA website.
I'm talking about Steph Curry.
It says one bad night or something worse,
which is the classic symptom of all these different sports outlets that,
you know,
someone just can't have a bad game.
All of a sudden it's got to be a,
Oh my God,
it's the fucking sky falling.
Okay.
So
anyways,
um,
I watched the,
I watch game too,
even though I know knew I had to be up by a,
had to be over at roll on Gals by fucking 11:00 AM so I had to be up at 10 in
the fucking hockey game.
Didn't come on until like fucking one in the morning.
So I was up till four in the morning watching that shit going.
I don't give a fuck.
I'm watching this shit.
And,
um,
first of all,
like an asshole.
I thought that I had to be over at the French Open at 11:00 AM cause I just
thought it was the men's finals and that was it.
And um,
by the way,
I'm sick of people giving me shit on Twitter for at the Stanley Cup finals my
whole life.
We call it the Stanley Cup finals.
It was the NBA finals and the Stanley Cup finals.
And people go,
there's not more than one final.
Well tell that to the fucking NBA.
All right?
I don't give a fuck.
You're fucking dramatic content.
I've watched all of them.
I've watched every Stanley Cup,
final or final,
whatever the fuck you want to call it,
since the fucking islanders.
Fourth Championship.
All right,
so you going back to 1983 of which 33 of them to go fuck yourself about whether
there's an s there or not.
I don't care.
And I also was calling it the Stanley Cup finals my whole fucking life.
And nobody ever gave me shit.
Once again,
maybe that's because now I just feel stupid and I'm lashing out at you.
Maybe you were just saying,
Hey,
bill,
not trying to be a dick,
but aids the Stanley Cup final.
That's how the NHL,
the League that you watched decides to call it,
whatever.
So I watched that shit,
the Stanley Cup final until uh,
4:00 AM cats and um,
okay,
so we fucking get up out of bed
and uh,
we go over to the fucking subway
and not trying to figure it out.
We,
we went into like the way you had to buy the a,
the tickets and it was really confusing,
super confusing.
There was all,
you know,
which,
how far into bout of Paris do you want to go?
There was like three different level of tickets to buy.
It was a complete fucking pain in the ass.
So we asked the lady in a,
behind the booth and she was a total content.
She was on the phone,
hated her fucking job,
was just an asshole.
This is nothing against French people are per regions because everybody's been
an absolute sweetheart to us over here.
Um,
and very patient as I try to speak French,
you know.
And,
um,
so we just said fuck it.
We got out and we got a cab.
Okay.
Yeah,
we cruised over and we get over there.
Right.
And we just breezed through.
There's like no fucking line.
You know,
I walk into the gift shop,
there's nobody in there.
I'm looking around,
I'm like,
wow,
this is some really ugly merchandise.
And then I realized it's the last day of the tournament,
all the good shit is gone,
which struck me as funny,
but I still got a Mug,
a hat and a shirt and the beach towel.
It was a big,
that was a big bucket list thing for me.
I always wanted to go to this fucking thing.
So in Nia,
this is the funniest thing ever.
She was so fucking,
she was over it before we even got there.
She doesn't give a fuck.
She did just did not give a shit on any level.
And I was asking her
about something,
I forget what she said and I just could tell the way she said it.
Um,
I was like,
Oh hey,
check it out.
You know,
I,
I didn't think they had my size by one over the other side.
I finally showed,
they actually had my size and she just goes,
oh yeah,
I just started,
I just burst out laughing,
which made her laugh.
And I was like,
I,
I just said to,
I said,
look,
I know you don't want to be here.
I know that like how you're feeling right now is how I feel when I sit down.
When you go to try something on at a fucking department store,
except this is going to take three fucking hours.
So I apologize.
You know,
let me go find you some booze,
right?
So I got her some champagne and shit and she's just trashing me and trashing
like the people that are there and all the fucking thing,
you know,
and just making me laugh my ass off.
And she's trying to be a sweetheart.
Go.
No,
no,
no.
I know this is a big thing for you.
I know you're,
you want to enjoy yourself here and then,
and how much,
just laugh,
go look at you.
You,
you want to just jump out of your own skin,
you sell,
don't want to fucking be here right now.
So,
um,
and all I'm doing is looking around going,
why isn't this barely anybody here?
Okay.
And then I thought,
I figured it out going,
oh,
I know why because there's only one match today.
Whereas before I've gone to these tennis tournaments and there's like,
you know,
this does the,
the semipro things going on on the,
the satellite courts,
there's like,
you know,
four or five d,
You know,
different matches going on to different venues.
Some people just have tickets for the first half of the day,
some for the whole day,
some for the late ones.
So there's this whole overlap and crowd.
Then I realized that that's not what it was.
I realized that it was 11:00 AM and that the men's final did not start until
3:00 PM and then what was actually happening at 12 noon was the final for the
women's doubles.
Okay.
Fucking class.
And I realized at that point that not only was near going to be there for three
hours of that she was going to be there for the three hours of the men final
men's final.
And,
uh,
and just the look on her fucking face.
I feel real bad.
I completely wore out,
um,
yesterday and uh,
so anyways,
and I'm sitting there going like,
I fucking hate doubles tennis.
So now it's like I owe it all.
I'm sick.
It's like we both could have still slept in because you sit sitting there like
zombies,
cause I kind of kept her up cause I was cheering on the game and everything.
And uh,
so we get over there and it's like,
well fuck can,
we might as well going in and watch the women's doubles final.
And I went in there and this is the most fucked up thing to the,
there was like fucking 70 people in the crowd
for a tennis major final.
And uh,
we went in there and I watched the fucking match and knee at some points.
Like,
Oh,
I'm gonna go down and go get a go get whatever the fuck a glass of wine or
something.
And she goes,
I need to walk around.
I'm gonna Fall Asleep because you know,
we've been sleeping until like one.
So we've just as it was still fucking jet lagged or whatever or whatever.
Cause we've been going out till four in morning,
who's getting no,
so she had to walk around just so she wouldn't fall asleep.
And I sat there and I watched the match and I totally fucking got into it and
there was one American plane,
Bethany help me say it right.
Maddix sands and I was watching her during the warmups and I was like going,
she's fucking good man.
And a then on the other team they had this really tall woman who played up near
the net the whole time and she was a fucking beast.
She was the shit and right out of the gate it just looked like the team with the
American one,
it was going to lose.
They just seemed over matched and all that and they lost the first set.
And I'm thinking like,
you know,
selfishly I'm thinking like,
oh well,
you know,
they lose the first set.
This'll be over quick.
You know what I mean?
They dropped the second set and then we're on to the men's fail,
right?
And uh,
they fucking came back
one the second set,
and then the other girls,
women,
they fucking bear down.
Hang on a second.
I've got to blow my fucking nose.
Hold up
and magically on back two seconds later.
So the other women,
they just fucking immediately the third set,
they just do just fucking come out swinging.
And it just looks like,
all right,
now they're going to take over.
They had to,
they had a little fucking brain fart in the second set.
And Dude,
it was like a heavyweight fight.
Then all of a sudden
the other girls started coming back.
I really should have their fucking names to championship names.
It was a Lucie Safarova,
Sephora rover and Bethany Madec Sands.
And they just fucking hung.
They're hung in there.
The fucking broke them.
And then they put the fucking hammered down and they ended up winning.
And it was a fucking awesome game.
And I swear to God there was 70 fucking people in the crowd.
I took a picture of it.
I'll try a fucking,
I'm not going to be able to upload it to like get back here cause I didn't get a
cell phone plan because I always get a cell phone plan when I go overseas and
they go,
yeah,
you have unlimited minutes and texting,
you'll get a bill for like 70 bucks.
And then I'd come home and it's always like fucking $400.
Okay.
You know,
you're always there for like 20 minutes and it says warning your router,
your fucking minutes for the day.
Um,
okay.
And then what are you going to do?
What are you going to do it?
You're not going to take calls or whatever.
So I just have not been on my phone.
I just shut the fucking thing off.
So anyways,
yeah.
So we watched that had a great time.
And then we came out and we were walking around and,
um,
and I dunno,
I was fighting this feeling because I always wanted to go to the French Open.
And there was something when I was at the French Open that was just fucking
bugging me and I couldn't figure out what it was.
And I was like,
in my jetlagged and my not join this,
cause I know my wife is enjoying this and
okay,
blah,
whatever.
So
we ended up going in to the men final,
right?
And,
uh,
it was,
Novak Djokovic against this guy who I never heard of.
Stan is SLAs while Rinca.
So I'm sitting there and I see that,
you know what's his face isn't in it.
Who's that fucking guy wins it every year.
Uh,
Raphael Nay down,
right?
They're fucking guy.
I Dunno.
He won nine of the last 10 of them.
It's insane.
He won in 2005,
six,
seven,
eight one,
two,
three,
four rows.
Anyone,
one,
two,
three,
four,
five in a row.
No one can ever get the sex
right.
Roger Federer won in 2009 fucking up his,
his,
uh,
his 10 year run.
Um,
but I mean that,
that's,
that's one of the one of them.
To me,
that's one of the greatest accomplishments in,
in modern day sports.
Fox One nine out of 10 championships at the pro level.
You got to go back to the Boston Celtics when they played in the 1960s and at
Ymc a league.
Right.
So anyways,
and I'm just looking at this other guy.
This Stan is loss while Rinko.
He's like ranked eighth.
And I lean over to my wife going,
I've got near man.
There you go.
This guy's got to get his fucking ass kicked.
All right.
Hey Dallas,
not in it.
I don't know shit about tennis.
Right.
I just watched the majors.
Um,
and I'm just like,
this guy's going to get his fucking ass kicked this,
this,
don't worry.
This will be over.
You know,
he'll probably one in three sets,
maybe four.
And so she's like,
okay.
All right.
So I'm sitting there watching the fucking thing.
In a Djokovich when's the first set?
And then the second set comes.
But,
but like he only broke what Rinko once and then the second set,
this will Rinca dude,
it's just fucking,
he's coming like a champ.
He breaks Djokovich twice and he ends up winning like he lost the first set,
six,
four and then he won the second set six,
four.
And when the,
um,
okay,
when the set was over,
when geographers are lost,
the second set,
he fucking,
uh,
he slammed his racket down on,
on the clay.
Any bounced up and he caught it and then he slammed it two more fucking times
and it broke and the whole crowd started bullying.
Right.
And,
and I,
that's when it hit me.
It's like that's what it is.
I don't like this fucking crowd.
I don't like the crowd that goes to tennis matches.
I don't like how they whistle when they get upset,
they hiss.
And if you show any sort of fucking emotion that's like anger,
like a,
in the first set,
I think a,
that while Rinca guy,
he fucking slammed his racket down twice on the net.
They bull.
Okay.
You know,
cause it's supposed to be a gentleman's game.
Get the fuck Outta here.
You're rich.
Cons.
How did you guys get your money?
Being a gentlemen,
you fucking bootleggers.
Gimme a break.
We've got a clothing line.
He got crying.
Children's so in the shit together and you're fucking sitting here now try to
tell people how to act like a fucking gentlemen.
All right,
this is me judging these fucking rich countries,
right?
So,
and I realized in that moment I was like,
that's why I don't fucking like this shit.
This is why I can never quite totally get into fucking tennis is because
whenever I go to to a live event,
there's that element there and fucking grey poupon pretending to be something
that you're not.
You know what I mean?
Like every time you stock doesn't go down,
you don't throw a chalice across the fucking,
your manner is just screaming at your stockbroker.
Give me a fucking break and now you're mad at this guy and his little short
shorts,
I love one.
We'll rank a slam the racket down.
I saw that he wasn't intimidated by,
I saw that it was fucking mad at himself and he wanted to fucking win.
I saw Djokovich after the first set,
when he won his first set,
he turned around and looked as coach and he pumped his fist and I was thinking,
this guy's dialed in and now there's something about tennis when you fucking
blow assent to have to start all over again.
Okay.
You know,
at Ground Zero and have to fight all of those fucking games again and,
and block out the fact that,
dude,
I could just be one set away.
Instead,
I'm tired and we've been playing for a fucking hour and a half and we're still
tied.
And this is annoying.
Like these,
all of that,
like those moments where you're starting to give the match away and it's like,
do you have it in you to come back?
And then you watch and the other person going,
does this person have it in him to finish this other guy off?
And um,
yeah.
So anyways,
one Rinca ends up winning the third scent.
So now he's up to the one and I'm like,
Jesus Christ,
what the fuck?
And then joke of it's just digs in.
His fucking comes out and when's the first three games of the fourth set?
And I'm like,
yeah,
this guy's got these,
got the championship gene,
this is going to go five.
And then this one rink,
a guy is going to have to think like,
wow man,
I had this guy in the ropes and I let him off and he's,
he going to have it in him to fucking come back.
So these guys are showing emotion and every time they show anger,
these fucking rich blue blood cons are bullying them.
It's like you're watching two fucking warriors down here when you're born,
the some of the best part of the game,
they get mad cause they want to,
when you're [inaudible],
this is phenomenal tennis.
So Eddie's,
well anyways,
fucking Stanislaus.
Just fucking
all of a sudden,
okay,
he's serving.
So then he wins.
It's three one and then he breaks Djokovich three two and then he wins his neck
servicing.
It's fucking three.
And I'm sitting there looking at,
nick ain't going like this might be over and forth.
This guy can fucking hang on and finish him off.
And then also you can finally go home and sleep.
And um,
okay.
That's what ended up happened.
Uh,
one weekend ended up coming back and it was,
it was a crazy thing because,
you know,
I don't watch a lot of tennis.
And so at first I was for Djokovich cause I knew that he had never won and he
was going to get the career Grand Slam,
which is basically winning on all three surfaces,
hardcore grass and clay.
And then this one rink a guy,
I don't,
I didn't think he'd have a one,
a major,
which I still don't think he did.
I don't know shit about tennis obviously.
And uh,
so I was kind of rooting for him.
Plus there was a ton of Djokovich fans.
So immediately it's like,
Oh man,
this,
you know,
fuck these rich content.
I want to see,
uh,
the Swiss,
the Swiss guy when just to watch all these people have to put their flags down.
Oh,
that was another thing too,
when people would yell out,
you know,
okay,
all these,
uh,
these,
what,
what is,
what does Djokovich she's,
I'm Serbian or something.
And when they would yell out all their Serbian shit,
like every once in a while somebody English speaking person would go,
shut up.
Yeah.
It's an,
I'm sorry,
I'm not supposed to cheer.
That's another thing.
Okay.
About certain these,
these fucking Hoity toity sports like golf and everything high very is to shut
the fuck up.
Has to be perfectly quiet.
If anybody liked fucking shuffles in this seat and takes a picture,
is somebody going to Putt or fucking to the,
Oh,
he hit the tennis ball like the,
the,
the athlete.
Go glares at him.
It's like,
are you fucking kidding me?
You hear what people do?
See what people are doing.
When somebody has taken a foul shot of fucking trying to kick a field goal,
these goddamn golfers and tennis players,
they'd start fucking crying.
So,
I don't know,
I'm not 100% sold on it,
but I will say it was,
it was one of the great events that I've ever been to and I would definitely go
to it again.
Um,
I wouldn't drag my wife to it.
Uh,
I've now been to three of the majors.
The only one left I have to go to is Wimbledon.
So next time I go to England or something,
I'll try to set it up around that and uh,
I'll go to that and I won't drag it to it.
It should be like,
no,
I want to go.
I like it.
I like to dress up and it's like you don't like it.
Um,
yeah.
So anyways,
that was a,
that was the experience.
And uh,
okay.
Another thing too,
when I got there,
you just can't believe I'm a fucking small.
It is.
It's like this major,
it's this big time championship and this,
it's this little intimate thing.
Like I swear to God,
just go,
go on stub hub and get tickets.
Sit at the top of the stadium.
It'll still be way better than any seats you'll ever get at an NBA final or a
Stanley Cup final or anything for the money.
And you're not even going to be that far away and everybody has to be so fucking
quiet.
You can actually hear him grunting and groaning like you sit in court side.
Um,
and then the tennis court is just super fucking small.
MMM.
It really is one of the great,
you know,
if you're going to go to a championship,
things as far as like a sporting event that you can then you can go to was
phenomenal.
And I absolutely,
uh,
you know,
I've never seen tennis playing on clay before.
So that was totally cool.
And then I also remembered that fucking hilarious chapter in John Mcenroe's book
where yeah,
he'd won Wimbleton,
he won the US Open,
he won the Australian Open and he needed the career Grand Slam to win the French
Open.
And one year he actually hadn't won.
And he ended up fucking up any,
blew it.
And every time he goes there to commentate,
he thinks about it.
And,
um,
I told you that great thing that he said that when he was fucking up one year
when he was fucking it up,
okay.
He screamed at the top of his lungs.
I hate this country.
Um,
which to me is one of the fucking great things every yelled out during a game.
And of course,
you know,
he got booed,
which probably made them play better in the next game,
which is why I love John Mcenroe.
So anyways,
so that was my big sporting event thing that I did on this trip.
And uh,
now that it's fucking over,
um,
looking back,
I think I'm just going to have him,
I dunno,
maybe more fun the next time I go to one.
And actually I still totally enjoyed it,
but I really got fucking annoyed
by them Bowen and when they showed any sort of emotion that wasn't gentlemanly
behavior,
I dunno that just fucking bug.
Maybe I'm an idiot.
I Dunno.
Anyways,
let's get Jesus Christ.
I just rambled for 31 fucking minutes.
Let's get to some,
uh,
skip through some advertising here.
You know,
it's just funny.
Every year around
father's day.
They always have,
you know the man great comes around.
All right,
here we go,
man.
Great everybody.
Attention Grill masters.
If your father is a man of exquisite tastes,
there is no finer gift and the ultimate steak house experience right in his very
own backyard,
man.
Great with a hundred percent cast iron grill grates the man.
Great.
What's a man great you ask man,
grades are American made high quality a hundred percent cast iron grate.
Sit.
Sit Right on top of your existing grades.
Too many greats of this weighing in at eight pounds.
No ounces a piece,
man.
Greats ensure a juicy,
juicy tender meat with no flare ups and a perfect cmax every time man and
grades.
Patented design,
deliver steakhouse quality flavor right at home.
Take advantage of the Monday morning podcast,
Father's Day special and get 40% off all cast iron grates and premium
brushes@mangreat.com when fans use bur 21
okay
for
21,
uh,
the number,
you don't have to spell it.
Relax.
Spend $50 or more.
This father's day with man,
great.
And Dad will receive a premium United States of bacon tee shirt.
Don't forget,
is it any wonder we die before women like mother's Day,
they getting like lotions and shit.
Yeah.
Cook some more red meat and profess your love of Bacon.
Don't forget to brush.
Everybody may great.
Has it designed their long bristle brush to get down deep between each rail.
Keep your grades in prime grilling condition.
Order by Monday,
June 15 for 15 for guaranteed arrival by father's day anywhere in the United
States.
Make sure to go to man,
great.com and enter my coupon code.
B U R r two one bird 21 at checkout.
Okay.
All right.
Oh boy.
Hey,
you like making great money,
right?
Sure.
We all do.
Here's a really cool opportunity that I evidently had to share with you.
Driving Uber,
driving with Uber.
Uber said Popular Smart Phone App that connects riders with drivers.
Uh,
evidently I take Uber a bunch.
Evidently I love them.
By the way.
I hate when they do this shit.
Uber is,
it is international.
They have it here in France.
You're doing great.
They don't need to have me say that.
I take it,
I don't fucking take it.
I take cabs,
I take cabs because nobody who drives a cab knows who the fuck I am.
All right.
But those Uber guys,
you know,
they're always like,
yeah,
that guy from the thing and then you live here.
So I don't,
I like getting my friend.
I still take cabs not set,
but I love over,
oh,
I get jealous.
Whatever.
My wife fucking takes it cause it it fucking come stay awake quicker than a cab.
It's the fucking way to go.
All right.
Unless you've been on,
I love the 80 [inaudible] then you got to,
you got to weigh your options or maybe tell him you live on a different street
and walk a block over.
All right?
So of them have really interesting stories as to why they drive with Uber.
What like cab drivers don't.
I used to be a doctor,
um,
in my country I was president.
Uh,
they love being their own boss.
They earn great money.
It's easy to start.
You just need a car in a license.
This is the part I love.
If I was,
uh,
you know,
I would,
I would definitely fucking do this.
I driving with Uber is great for anyone who needs flexibility,
mobility,
parents.
This is a really easy way to work around your family schedule students,
you can make some extra money between classes.
Now's the prime time to cash and driving with Uber.
You'll thank me for telling you how to get paid every week.
I could be getting into your car when you drive with Uber.
Yeah,
I'm for my wife.
A call to action.
You got a car and a license.
Put a both to work and start earning serious life changing money.
Sign up with Uber.
Visit drive with uber.com.
That's drive with Uber U B E r.com with uber.com.
That is a fucking great way to make money.
You already got your car,
you making payments on it.
Why not make it fucking work for you.
There you go.
I totally understand it.
All right.
Dollar Shave club,
everybody.
All right.
People fed up who still had,
evidently I'm fed up who still hasn't joined dollar shave club.
There are some no,
I'm serious.
Their raises are amazing and it's more convenient and cost a fraction of the
price.
What's the issue?
Still don't get it.
Here's how the club works.
Go to dollar shave club.com and pick up one of the three great razors,
the two blade humble twin,
the four blade,
four x in this.
If you're a fucking Werewolf,
the six blade executive,
I guess that's what I use now.
I doubt,
uh,
you get your first box in about a week.
It includes a free handle in a sleeve of blade cartridges.
It's high quality stuff.
Got that weight to it.
Like the expensive ones I've used before.
Oh God,
this is making my teeth hurt.
My exec had six stainless.
I don't have a fucking exec.
I understand you sell it and I will help you fucking sell it and I understand.
It's great.
Stop saying I have it when I doubt.
All right.
Does the execs has six stainless steel blades in 90 degree pivot head and the
aloes strip.
All right.
You'll never get a shave like this.
After that,
they tried to say,
I never got to shave like that.
I personally,
I think two blades is all you need.
One sucks.
Two is the perfect one.
Anytime you get three or more,
you even with my cute little button nose,
I've got a son adjust to my nose because it can't get fucking under there.
All right,
you made me say that dollar shave club,
they putting fucking words in my mouth.
All right.
After that,
they mail you for replacement blades every month or every other and you'll never
have to worry about it again.
That's it.
If you haven't joined,
you're missing out.
Simple as that.
Try Dollar Shave club.com/bur bur.
That's dollar shave club.com/burr a father's day is around the corner and dollar
shave club makes a great,
great gift.
There you go.
I don't understand why they're to make me say I'm doing all this shit.
It's a fucking great product.
They totally rip you off at the drug store.
These fucking people got the same quality razors.
You sign up for this shit and they bring them to you in the,
and there you go.
You get,
you get that 20 minutes of your life back every fucking week or every month,
whatever the hell you did.
Why can't you just write copy like that?
Why do you to sit there and say,
I have that shit.
I don't have that shit.
Oh God,
I'm going to cunty mood.
Huh?
All right.
Um,
all right.
Oh,
I saw this,
this fucking story.
It's really annoyed.
The shit out of me.
Surprise,
surprise.
It said,
uh,
is this is this cute little fucking story and God knows the Internet either
likes a,
we should burn this person at the stake story or this little cute s story.
Like,
you know,
I thought my life is over and then this kitten showed up and what happened next
will bring you tears of joy.
I've,
I refuse to,
this kittenish showed up.
I fucking refused to read any of those and I have never told any you guys,
uh,
you know,
I just need you to just,
could you do me,
us?
Do me a favor,
please stop clicking on those.
You know what I mean?
I was sitting on a park bench in a wizard,
walked up to me and what he had to say next will change your life.
And then you get on there and it's,
it's like a quarter of the story and then you got to fucking figure out how to
click.
It's just,
it's what does it click bait.
That's what they call it.
All right.
And I'll tell you,
I fucking was able to figure it out.
After falling forward about 162 times,
I realized that all the stories sounded fake.
None of this shit was really inspiring.
I never cried.
I never laughed.
I just got fucking annoyed and I had a bunch of pop up ads.
So,
um,
I just,
I dunno,
you don't have to deal,
could continue to click on it.
Pull the fuck am I to tell you what to do.
But I always laugh when I read those now and you wouldn't believe what happens
next.
You won't believe what happens next is I scroll onto the next fucking story,
a Douche.
Um,
by the way,
I love Facebook.
I absolutely love it.
And don't give a fuck if it makes me sound like an old man.
I am an old man and I like how they have all these interesting stories picked
out for me by some of the Douche on Facebook rather than having to try and find
them myself.
So anyway,
so,
um,
okay.
Scrolling through the Facebook as US older people say and um,
there was just supposed to be this cute,
heartwarming fucking story.
It was about how people were delayed for six hours.
Okay.
In the airport,
but through some unbelievable miracle,
the cast of the lion king and Aladdin was there at the airport.
Right.
And they're acting like this is some fucking amazing thing.
It's like,
no,
this is the cast of the traveling fucking show.
This is what these people do.
Cause after it's a hit on Broadway,
the people then want to make money and take it around the country for people who
don't have time,
the money.
Okay.
Or whatever to fucking go to New York.
No country can't go to New York and squeeze it to that theater.
So they have a couple of traveling shows.
So Lo and behold,
you imagine this,
you're at the fucking airport.
Your flight is delayed six hours.
And then for some reason,
the fact that the cast of the lion king and Aladdin is there,
like this was supposed to be heartwarming,
that it made it like a better thing.
Okay,
this is what happened.
They started singing the fucking songs
to a Latin or the lion king.
Just imagine you're sitting there stuck in a fucking,
and then all of a sudden some dude starts doing this.
Oh my God,
will you shut the,
would you guys shut the fuck up?
Shut the fuck up.
Right?
Isn't that what you would say?
The last fucking thing I would need is I'm sitting there hating my fucking life
is somebody go,
wow,
okay.
You ever think that most people fucking hate Broadway shows?
All right.
I,
I don't,
you know,
there's a very,
there's very few people that actually enjoy Broadway shows.
Okay.
It's children.
It's the gay community.
MMM.
Oh my God,
I can't say the next group because then I'll just get them.
I'm just picturing,
you know,
and then,
I don't know.
I don't,
It's fucking people or old people,
you know what I mean?
Who went to,
who went to funny girl in Oklahoma?
And they actually,
you know,
when movies back in the day when they're dead be,
you'll be watching a movie and all of a sudden the middle,
you have the dialogue.
They would just break out and do a song and they would start dancing.
It's like leftover Vaudevillian horse shit.
And,
uh,
you know,
this is like a kid's movie that you've turned into a fucking musical.
So it sucks on two levels.
Now you've married two fucking things.
All right?
Very,
very rarely is a kid's movie like,
like a toy story is great.
All right.
But I gotta be honest with you,
the whole fucking,
you know,
like pretty much the rest of them,
like bugs bunny is funny.
You know what I mean?
Pinky and the brain.
It's funny.
Spongebob squarepants is fine.
Sesame street is funny because they'd throw in jokes for adults,
but a lot of them,
you know what I mean?
The care bears the fucking,
uh,
at a Munchie g or whatever the other ones are.
And then it's like munch Chichi.
Remember that?
Mon Chichi Munchie G.
Oh,
so soft and cuddly.
Mon Chichi.
Munchie G it's a creepy monkey.
Right?
They would turn that into a fucking musical.
Okay.
And then your girlfriend or your gay uncle or Yo,
you're fucking,
you know the person who was in the sugar salt fucking problem.
Right?
Some fatty will take you to the God damn thing and he got to sit there.
All right.
But at least you're prepared for it.
When you go to a Broadway show,
the last fucking thing you need a,
I mean is,
oh my God.
And the only thing worse than those fucking people singing that horse shit would
be the people standing around enjoying it.
The looks on their faces.
Oh my God.
Can you believe it?
They sang and luck angels.
Right.
Okay.
They're not the first fucking horrible,
the whole fucking thing is horrible.
And it was probably written by some white dude in somewhere in Africa.
It's probably really offensive that
wow
fucking talk and lines and all that shit and turn into place into this magical
mystery tour.
Right?
The same way when Aladdin came out,
people from the Middle East,
hey to dead horse shit as we ate it up.
Oh my God.
Robin Williams rest his soul was fucking hilarious.
Is the Latin right?
As if flying on carpets coming out of tea kettles,
they didn't like that shitty that they didn't like 300.
They didn't like any of that fucking horse shit.
Now you've got these kinds of singing at the airport for the love of God.
They should have made them go walk into that little fish tank where they make
smokers go to go fucking sing in there.
Alright.
Jesus Christ.
I'm in a fucking goofy.
What'd you,
what'd you know?
I'm on vacation right now and am gay,
Patti.
Um,
I hate that shit.
I gotta be honest with you.
I'm a bit of the Grinch.
MMM.
I have major issues with a heartwarming stories.
They never make me emotional.
They make me fucking angry like that singing there made me fucking angry.
But,
uh,
I'll tell you the things that make me actually get like emotional,
where I almost started tearing up is,
uh,
what I watched kids fighting on youtube and I'll see the kid,
that shit a lost all of a sudden flip out and beat the kid that,
that should have beat him.
That actually will make me emotional.
Now,
I don't know what that says about me,
but um,
you know,
I dunno,
whatever it,
maybe that's just not for me.
Oh my God.
I've been into so many,
so many fucking airports and there's so much shit to annoy you.
The last thing you need and out of all the fucking songs to break into,
you break into that fucking
that whatever the fuck that is like that helium balloon.
What does,
what does that shit?
People you suck on like helium.
I mean that's like,
that was what was just happening.
There was like 40 Yoko Ono's all at the same time in harmony singing some horror
like that.
No.
Some shit that yoga would have screamed out while the Beatles were playing,
thinking that she was adding to the music.
All right.
I might get some complaints over that one.
You know,
people like,
you know,
I always feel like
there's something sad about people who go to Broadway shows.
That's not even true because what's his face?
The South Park guys did like the greatest one ever that I would have gone to,
but you know,
they was sold out for like nine years and at that point I just go,
I don't want to do this.
You know what I mean?
Are you guys like me?
Like I just like,
if there's a line,
I just,
I just say,
well,
you know,
evidently I'm not going to have that experience.
That's how I just,
I don't feel like there's ever a reason to stand in a fucking line unless you
were in a,
in a,
you know,
a labor camp.
Okay.
And the,
and the handed up slop,
right.
That was Kim who I'll stand in line to go see a fucking,
a good showing a rock star or something like that.
But like if,
if there's like a fucking
okay.
You see how he just suddenly covered myself there.
If I fucking,
I got to clarify this,
like,
okay.
If they go,
oh my God,
this place has the best fucking burgers and I show up in,
there's a line around the block.
I just go,
well,
I guess I'm never going to have one.
Yeah,
that,
fuck.
What are we,
what are we in?
Russia was standing a fucking bread line here.
I'm not doing that.
Okay.
Why don't you fucking assholes.
Get a bigger space and add some more fucking tables.
Right.
Is that Ron did this whole thing just go off the fucking rails.
I don't even,
I don't even know.
All right,
let's get to some questions here for the week.
Um,
did I get through everything?
All I know is I'm really excited to get home and I'm home for like four days and
I go back out on tour and uh,
I am so Jones and to do fucking stand up,
um,
okay.
I,
I got this fucking Ms. Bruce Jenner idea that I want to do that has nothing.
Yeah.
Actually,
I'm not making fun of what he did and what he did actually make me feel,
considering his accomplishments made me feel like less of a man.
So that's going to be my angle on the whole thing.
All right,
here we go.
Raging bull.
Dear Billy,
the raging bull.
Uh,
I don't know what that means.
Bullshit.
Or maybe I was once a financial banker.
Yes.
One of those rotten scoundrels at where a monkey suit and work like a tool
alongside other corporate douche bags.
It took me a few years to actually see how shitty this industry really was
filled with Douchey.
Constant would do anything to get ahead.
I fucking hated it.
One day a work colleague,
colleague asked me to help him train for one of those white collar charity
boxing events.
It basic,
it's basically an event when a regular corporate dude laces up a pair of gloves.
Oh,
corporate dudes.
I've seen that.
And they fight each other and they have to go out in a boxing ring.
All the raised money for some cutthroat charity.
I know,
right?
Um,
oh,
by the way,
somebody gave me shit for reading that thing about the Red Cross going there,
there's a great organization and you totally classified them as being pieces of
shit just because of one bad.
And it's like,
no,
I didn't.
I actually said that,
I don't know if part of this is because of what's going on down in Haiti,
but blah,
blah,
blah.
And as I did that,
I remembered like,
wait a minute,
didn't they get shit for uh,
what they did during nine 11.
So actually wrote the guide Blatt back.
I was like,
no,
I didn't.
I didn't trash it.
But by the way,
here's another article.
All right,
with your precious Red Cross.
Um,
anyways,
I,
he said I've been competing since I was in college and it was more of a hobby
than anything else.
So I agreed to help my coworker with some of his training.
After arriving at my coworkers boxing gym and watching some of the other
corporate monkeys hit the heavy bag and spar,
I really wanted to enter myself into this event.
Ah,
dude,
you're a real fucking ring.
Uh,
he said these corporate noodles couldn't punch themselves out of a wet paper
bag.
And I thought how satisfying it would be to beat the living shit out of one of
these aspiring douchey banker cunts.
A dude,
come on man,
you can't do that.
Um,
although it would be kind of funny.
It body shuts funny.
He can't hit him in the head.
Anyways,
he said,
I went over the idea with my boxing coach.
He really didn't approve of the notion of a trained fighter ripping up some
regular Joe smoke.
Exactly.
He goes,
so unfortunately I didn't enter the event.
To this day.
I still regret not having the chance to trash one of those corporate douche is
in the ring.
It would have felt so sweet.
Right.
Question to you is if you had some sort of formal training and comp,
a combat sport and there was a chance for you to enter a celebrity boxing event,
uh,
would you love to,
who would you love to fight?
It could be another comedian,
celebrity sports figure.
Anyone who would be across the ring from you to pummel a longterm update.
I have since left that soul sucking corporate gig to pursue a year of world
travel yet with the blood money and competition of boxing.
I'm just fucking with you too.
God bless you.
Have a good time.
Uh,
seeing you live in Toronto,
Pittsburgh in Brisbane,
Australia,
uh,
keep kicking ass bill.
Um,
all right.
Okay.
All right.
If I was formally trained in combat,
like there's no way I would fight someone else unless they were formally trained
or if they were trying to hurt me.
Come on.
You can't fucking do that.
But I'm saying as how I'm not formally trained,
who would I want to fight and I get to win the toughest fucking guy out there.
So I look like a stud.
Um,
there's really nobody I want to beat the shit out of.
Is there,
I fight the cast of a Latin?
Nah,
I wouldn't do that.
That's just a loose,
loose,
either you'd beat up a bunch of fucking Broadway singers or worse,
you lose to them.
Um,
okay.
I'll tell you,
I,
let me tell you who I wouldn't fight.
Uh,
I wouldn't fight Joe Rogan.
There's a long list of people that I wouldn't fight,
uh,
Mark Wahlberg.
I wouldn't fight him.
MMM.
You know,
I love to,
was all the people listening right now going to write fucking kid dead guys.
This what'd you,
what'd Ya,
I don't think you would.
Um,
who else?
Ving Rhames I wouldn't fight.
Ving Rhames you know what it is?
It's the people that,
that like either in shape or they just have a certain fucking vibe about them.
Were you just like,
yeah,
it would fuck with that guy.
Uh,
there's a lot of people,
I wouldn't fight 247 next weekend.
Most of Hollywood.
I wouldn't fight most of Hollywood.
I would fucking lose too.
Uh,
I,
you know,
I throw a fucking little girly jab and I would,
I would,
I would hang on in the crowd,
would boo like,
you know,
when you get ripped off at a pay per view,
like that's what my flight would look like.
Um,
no,
I was kidding who.
I get her a couple times and then I would start spasming out and I'd fucking
just start doing the windmill punches before the person just sat in the pocket
and caught me with a good fucking,
I dunno,
left Hook and just drop me.
Sit right on the seat of my pants.
Make weird noises.
All right.
Uh,
girlfriend,
a whore.
Hey Nia.
That's probably still sleeping.
All right.
I like to have her for these fucking things.
All right,
girlfriend.
A whore in my walk of shame.
Hey Bill on 22 years old and I've been dating a lady for a few months now.
Thanks in.
Been going great.
We click,
we clicked really well and she's beautiful.
This is a funny,
all of these starts this way.
Everything's she,
she's beautiful.
Okay.
It says in elegant girls,
I think you meant to say it's all one word.
I n e l.
E.
G.
A.
N.
T inelegant and elegant girl.
I Dunno.
With a a great job.
Things were going great until recently.
She still lives at home and one night she asked me to come over for a late night
booty call.
Oh,
Jesus.
What's wrong with that dude?
Just girls a champ so far.
Of course I show up to a parent's house and get into bed with her.
Oh,
she lived at home with their parents.
Okay.
It's kind of weird.
As I laid down,
as I laid down,
I sat on a vibrating sex toy.
She was embarrassed and played it off like,
oh,
I just found this recently when I was cleaning through my stuff,
I acted like I didn't care.
But in my head I was screaming,
what the fuck,
dude,
why are you acting like you didn't fucking rub one out like the day before?
Yeah,
but I use my hand.
I went all natural.
What are you looking at her like?
She's a fuck.
She's using p days here.
Um,
anyways,
we go at it and I spend the night at her place.
I love how you were like,
what the fuck?
But you still banged her classic guy moved to this chick's a fucking psycho.
One of fuck.
Okay.
In the morning.
It turns out she wasn't home alone.
Her Dad was home.
And when I do the walk of shame and I do the walk of shame out of the House,
Oh my God,
the Dad's side saw you o m g on top of this weight on top of it.
This was the first time meeting her dad.
We didn't say a word to each other and he just gave me this death glare that
screened this motherfucker.
Just Bang my daughter in my house.
Oh my God.
Her Dad flipped his shit on her and once in a move out she asked me if it's cool
if she lives with the two guys from work.
I tell her I don't care.
But again,
I'm thinking,
uh,
what in the actual fuck is going on here basically.
How do you think I should play this out?
Should I cut my losses and get out?
I tried to stick it out.
I feel like those are some serious red flags,
but I really liked this girl and until this point,
things were perfect.
Maybe the lovely Nia could help.
Yeah,
she needs to help.
I would say this.
Um,
uh,
yeah,
she could have been a little,
she could have handled that situation a little better.
Uh,
with her dad.
Christ,
I don't think knee is up,
so
what do I do?
Do I disappoint you guys are dilemma.
Do I let my wife sleep on the vacation?
Let's go wake up my wife.
Hang on.
Okay.
Bull Zuma.
Dom Nia,
can you help me out with a question here?
Are you still sleeping?
Yeah.
All right.
I'll give it to you real quick.
Here's the deal.
This kid's 22 weeks with this girl.
She's fucking perfect.
Everything's wonder,
wonder.
Everything's wonderful.
All right.
Uh,
so she calls him up one night for booty call.
He goes over there.
She's still living at home.
Is that hard of parents are at home?
So he goes up there.
He goes like,
I get into the bed and me that we sit on one of the vibrating sex toys and he's,
she tries to play it off like,
oh,
that's just something I found what I was going through my stuff and he said he
was,
he played it off.
I was like,
what the fuck?
He thought it was weird.
He's 22,
so she fucking,
they bang,
he wakes up the next morning and it turns out her fucking dad is home,
so he's got to do the walk of shame right past her dad.
Oh.
And the guy is just glaring at him.
Like if you just fucked my daughter in my own house,
get the fuck out of here.
So he gets the fuck out of there.
Right.
And then,
uh,
like
the next day at work or something,
she goes,
yeah,
my dad's pissed at me.
He wants me to move out.
Do you mind if I move in with two guys from work?
And he's like,
part of them,
you know,
likes the girl.
And the other part is like,
you know,
there,
there are too many red flags here.
What's red flag about it?
Uh,
that I dunno.
They
do.
She got to turn towards the mic.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Shit.
Yeah.
Sorry,
I had the fucking recorder.
Yeah.
Um,
what's red flag about it?
Well,
first of all,
it's white girlfriend.
She's just said booty call earlier.
Right.
So if you're talking about boutique,
it's,
it's the beginning of a relationship here.
And he's like,
do I pursue this?
I want to ask her why she thought it was necessary to ask him permission about
where she wants to live.
Right.
But obviously that's not the situation here.
Move in with two guys that they work with.
And I mean,
and that's a little fucking,
well,
what if,
okay,
let's flip the tables.
You and I just started looking up.
Hey,
is it okay if I move in with these two chicks and we both work with,
oh,
they all work together.
Yup.
What am I fucking Jack tripper.
You're not gonna have a problem with that.
Boop,
boop,
boop.
I think you,
I think kids these days,
they,
uh,
they lived together,
males and females,
and it's not like a big deal.
So,
um,
now if I were her,
if I were like her mom,
I think it'd be a different story.
But,
um,
no,
I,
I don't understand.
Well,
because I had,
you know,
because I would just be like a mom about it,
you know?
But as,
as a guy who was just a hanging out with her.
Yeah,
but you just,
she just fucking banged you when her dad was home and then made you just fucking
doesn't even have the decency to be like,
Hey,
my dad's home,
you might want to go out the fucking window and you walk by the dead.
Like he's like that.
He's done like what's,
what's he going to do having a relationship come over for fucking thanksgiving?
Like his first fucking meeting is yet.
Yeah.
I fucking just railed your daughter right up above you.
Like if
he was,
if he was mature at all,
he would have been like,
oh good morning.
You know,
my name is so and so and I just fucked your daughter.
Well obviously you don't say that,
but what the fuck?
What are we reading all night?
No,
you say hi,
you know,
I'm friends with such and such and how are you,
you do the respect thing.
The respecting was to not say a fucking word to sit there and come down and be
like,
hello,
how are you in?
And try to play it off like you didn't fuck is insulting that man's
intelligence.
Well,
it again anyway,
getting back to the,
no,
no.
Let's,
let's,
let's stay with that point there.
Okay.
There's no way out of that situation other than,
than what he did.
The most thing that he could have done was not saying anything because he's at
least as a man addressing the fact that he understands that what the fuck he
did,
even though it wasn't on purpose,
was ridiculously kind of fuck with this guy's head.
I disagree.
I think we should have done is been respectful and said,
and like he saw him like you walked by his dad.
Yeah,
he was,
yeah.
He walked by and the guy in the guy's staring fucking daggers at.
Yeah.
They didn't fucking 22 years old.
Oh,
I'm just,
I'm just saying,
I think it would have been better if he had a introduced himself because that's,
can you please do that to me?
I'll play this ad.
I'll respectable thing to do.
I'll play the deck.
You don't just walk through somebody like,
uh,
a grown person's house and not say anything.
That's something my parents would have about like,
you know,
you don't just walk in my house and the,
you know what I mean?
Like almost saying what you're saying it,
but it has to,
it can't be more than two words.
Like I would have just looked at him.
I would have been,
I'm sorry,
but here's how we're talking about the red flag situation,
right?
The red flag is that he's,
he's,
this girl is sexual and so that to him as a red flag and you know what baby
doll,
you need to fucking get over it.
You know something.
I understand where you're going with this,
where it's just like,
if a guy's is just like you do,
all right.
Maybe she wasn't smart about putting away her vibrators.
Maybe she was thinking that you might be kind of like,
oh,
what is this?
But you know,
you're 22 you probably don't know how to use it or don't quite understand what
it's about.
He's 22 he doesn't need it.
It's Dick is standing at attention when he fucking wakes up in the morning for
him.
I don't mean for him.
I meant for like they could,
he could use it on her.
Like that's what I meant the fuck.
Do you think I meant you said he doesn't need it as if I'm saying that she
would,
you know what I'm saying?
Like he doesn't need it to pleasure her.
Jesus Christ.
Let me,
there's from what I was saying,
okay,
but there's other,
there's other ways that 22,
I know,
Bill,
I'm saying that that's fucking,
you can have like a nice strong dick that goes all night,
but you can also use a vibrator as well.
Like,
you know this,
don't make me explain this to you.
You know what I'm talking about.
I do.
Okay.
All right.
Thank you for giving me credit.
Um,
listen to you.
I don't have a,
I agree with,
you know,
whatever.
All right.
He's,
he's not ready for it.
It's fine.
The point is that he,
it's fine.
Maybe one day he will be.
Um,
but the fact that it's seeds us was like,
oh my God,
this is a sexual girl and she doesn't really give a fuck who knows it.
Right.
Whether it's me who
came over for a booty call because I'm like,
Whoa,
what's this vibrator doing here?
Or you know,
her dad.
So she was,
you took it now?
No,
I'm just trying to think how you miss took that.
Like when I said his dick stands up when he wakes up,
like he needs to use her vibration because dick go up like,
and it doesn't even make any sense to me.
I,
I didn't think it made sense either,
but it was obviously,
yeah,
I was looking at it like it was like the stunt Dick.
Like that's what like when you know those old guys in the steak houses who have
like the fucking chicks half their age,
like they show up with like a bag of like fucking Viagra and like the vibrator
because you know,
to keep her interested as they're waiting for the blue pill.
That to kick in.
That's how I was looking at it.
Jesus Christ as fucking clarify this shit.
So anyways,
my,
my thing is Sonya is,
yeah,
like just the situation that she put herself in and put him in where he then has
to walk by the dad.
I mean the whole fucking thing is just taken on water right now.
No,
it's this very messy.
It's,
it's,
it's a very messy situation for sure.
So there might be a lack of maturity on her side.
The wish these ready to like man,
if they're,
yeah,
they're both 22 I think that goes without saying,
but yes.
Okay.
Just won't give them this girl any sort of criticism here and yet,
listen,
I said,
I just said they're both,
they're both 42 we've already,
she's already shit all over this guy.
I'm just saying like how am I shitting all over the guy?
I'm just saying it's too early to get involved in this fucking argument.
Let's,
let's just,
let's just plow ahead.
Let's just plow ahead here.
What is the point that you are trying to get me to address here is that is maybe
she's not ready to be in a fucking,
she just got kicked out of our house for fucking another guy in the house.
Yeah.
Okay.
That's,
you know,
that's not a very stable situation.
Again,
involved in,
first of all,
you're 22 years old so you're still picking in the first round.
It's not like the guy's 42 when he's single and he's going to take what's out
there.
There's a whole bunch of fucking,
you know this,
this is,
this is like you hit the NBA draft lottery.
You get like the first fucking pick in the draft here.
You're going to go with the fucking a woman who just got kicked out of our house
for fucking you while her dad was still home.
When you walked by Your Dad.
All the vibrators,
shit in anything out.
Who gives a fuck about all of that?
The fuck that part there.
I'm saying does he really need to hitch his wagon to that?
So he's asking if he should like pursue a relationship because we're really
cause everything else,
everything else other than her fucking two doors down from the dad and then
having him walk by the dad.
I mean,
there are some things in the,
that right in the beginning,
despite of how nice you are and everything,
there are some things that make you kind of go like,
Hey,
you know what?
You know,
relationships are hard either when you're with the right,
you know?
Geez.
Um,
yeah,
no,
I mean it,
it,
I,
I would say young man that is,
you just trash you're of send it to the camera.
I understand.
I'm just,
I'm just trying to be funny.
Excuse me.
Um,
Jesus fucking Christ.
I know you're the professional comedian than relationship.
Why am I here then?
You know?
No,
you were trashing the guy so bad.
I thought that that was another part of the trashing who we're just not a,
we're not,
uh,
and,
and sync there this morning,
that Kiddo.
Um,
I would say that,
uh,
yeah,
you,
it doesn't sound like a,
she's the girl for you.
How about that?
There we go.
That's that.
That was a sofa.
Hey,
I did that whole thing to leave out.
Why?
I don't think so.
Yeah,
I know why.
Cause he's,
he cause cause he's not mature enough to handle a fucking blah,
blah,
blah.
You there?
Obviously they're both of them.
If you are,
don't you know I like about me walking away.
Should your voice is fading away in the background.
I got to go downstairs.
Yeah.
We're the,
we're the,
we're the fucking uh,
questions are no,
that's it.
All right.
And your little attic loft here.
Don't set up too quickly.
You'll hit your head on the beam again.
No,
no.
Jesus.
Of,
why am I done?
Uh,
we got a little tree for department here.
Um,
all right,
here we go.
Well that was a fucking waste of God.
Damn.
I thought,
I thought she was finally going to agree with me just one of these times.
I want her to fucking agree with me.
She just wants do it.
She just will not do it.
All right.
Um,
AH,
fuck.
This thing's going to take forever to load this fucking slow ass internet here.
Let's uh,
I got to read a couple of more advertising in.
I'll blow through these last couple of questions.
All right.
Trunk Club,
everybody.
Trunk Club.
Guys,
you might hate shopping,
but you still want to look good,
right?
What did,
you could snap your fingers and have a trunk full of clothes that fit perfectly
and make you look amazing.
You're going to love what you get delivered.
Uh,
you gotta love it gets delivered to you from Trunk Club at Trunk,
trunk club.com/.
Bar.
You answer a few simple questions about your look style and size,
and then they assign a real person who helps to style you.
They email you a list of clothes,
they recommend sending you a,
they recommend sending you,
you approve it at no cost to you.
They ship a trunk full of fresh new clothes to your door.
Try them on,
keep what you want,
send back what you don't in their prepaid box.
That's it.
A better wardrobe.
Then he could ever pick out yourself in minutes.
So maybe you could pick out of just to go to wardrobe,
but if someone else is going to fucking do it,
why do you need to do it?
Right?
Did I mentioned the services free your stylist,
the shopping,
the box,
even the shipping all 100% free when you go to trunk club.com/bar only paid for
the closure.
Keep no ongoing subscriptions,
no hidden charges,
no malls.
Just great close hand picked for your style.
All right,
uh,
you're going to thank me on this and right now it's completely free.
Go get started@trunkclub.com slash bar today.
That's trunk club.com/.
Bar.
All right,
and lastly,
but not leastly legal zoom.
Are you the next world famous entrepreneur or maybe you don't care about fame?
I do.
You just want to help people,
uh,
whatever your motivation.
If you're an innovator,
it's easy to lunch your dream this month with legal zoom.
Incorporate a form,
an LLC to start your business.
Register your trademark and protect your products and services.
Apply for a patent to secure your invention.
These are all fragments and they keep having like apply for a patent to security
of invention.
Is that a frame with register your trademark to protect your products and
services?
Don't you need a subject?
You should fucking know.
Maybe I'm wrong,
Bill.
Why you're diagramming sentences.
Just read the God Damn Park.
Over the past decade,
legal zoom has helped more than a million people just like you turn their ideas
into reality.
So what's special about this month?
Well,
for a limited time,
you can get special savings on any trademark copyright,
a provisional patent application,
go to legalzoom.com today to get started.
They even can help you if you have a great idea,
but you're not sure where to begin.
Sense they are not a law firm.
You can get advice from legalzoom's network of independent attorneys in most
states.
That means you can get the guidance you need to get your great idea off of the
ground.
Don't forget to enter bur bur and the referral box at this month,
uh,
at checkout this month for your special discount,
legalzoom.com Promo Code [inaudible] legal help is here.
All right.
Um,
all right.
What am I right now?
All right,
sister is a cunt.
Jesus.
All right.
Hey there.
Ginger had myth though.
I get it.
A little play on words there.
Oh,
Jesus.
Uh,
I'm a 20 year old guy who desperately needs advice from,
from their favorite comedian,
from his favorite comedian.
So I'll get to the point,
my sister is a cunt.
Jesus Christ.
This guy's not pulling any punches here to give you a small sample of her.
I'll elaborate a bit.
All right,
so you can get a small sample.
You're going to elaborate this guys just fucking,
he he's,
he's,
he's young in Yangon.
He's zigging and zagging.
Uh,
she's a narcissist.
Nina Yang.
It was bad.
She's a narcissist to her very core in straight up stupid.
She sounds like she's hot.
She's abusive to my dad.
Oh,
she's definitely good looking.
Even though he has cut his Roman half to accommodate her moving into a small
apartment.
She hurls insults at him and when she doesn't get her way and talk shit under a
breath,
um,
when she hurls insults at him when she doesn't get away and talk shit under a
breath so we can't hear it.
But I can and it's fucking infuriating.
My Dad is a really,
is really is a good man who has worked as a teacher for nearly 30 years and I
respect the hell out of him.
It kills me to see or treat him like yesterday's dog shit also.
She's a massive whore.
Jesus' body.
This is your sister since I almost,
no,
I,
I almost know that she sucks Dick for weed.
All right dude.
This is getting sad here.
Truly.
She is one of the most ugly and insensitive people that could ever exist.
In addition to that,
she loves to talk about how good she looks.
She's lost a lot of weight and while I was supportive at first,
she rapidly became,
began to make fun of me and made me feel bad about my body to proper self up.
Dude,
this is like a reality show.
This is sad on so many different levels.
Uh,
fun fact.
She starved herself,
became a believer.
Mick took weight loss pills and never worked out.
Yeah.
So what the fuck is that bitch?
The right to say anything to anyone about how they look.
All right dude.
You get a lot of anger towards your sister.
You established this.
Now I need your help with your unique attitude of take.
No Shit Dude.
I take plenty of shit.
How do you handle,
it's easy to do not take any shit.
Was was a fucking individual on a podcast,
not talking to anybody.
How do you handle someone like that?
I'm sure you've met hundreds like her.
What can you say?
What can you do to rein in this psycho bitch?
She abuses my dad.
She treats my little brother and I like total shit and she doesn't do anything
to keep the place clean.
So that usually falls on my dad and I.
All she does is use people and when they aren't useful anymore she discards them
like trash.
She's truly someone I've grown to despise and resent.
I try and keep her out of my mind as much as possible to keep my own sanity.
Uh,
I would have disowned her,
but since she lives with me it's makes it difficult.
I feel bad for my dad because he has to watch my sister and I argue,
I always have my dad's back and yell at her when she said some of our usual crap
that doesn't really do it anymore.
But that doesn't really do it anymore.
I'm not someone who has problems with a lot of people.
Most of the people I've met who know her or have told me similar horror stories.
If you can't think of anything to suggest,
I gladly accepted.
If you just bashed her on the podcast,
it won't solve anything,
but it will give me something to smile about.
What I see that dumb bitch come hopping into the living room and acting like
your shit doesn't stink.
Thanks for hearing me out.
Bill all the best to Unia and Cleo.
All right.
Um,
well you are living in some cramped quarters,
so that's definitely going to make you guys not like each other.
Um,
it doesn't seem like your dad calls her out on her behavior.
So,
um,
I would say I would start working on my own life,
which is I would make enough money to move out and I,
it's a,
she's truly as horrible as you're saying.
I would,
uh,
try to just see her on Thanksgiving and Christmas and um,
you know,
that stuff about her being the limit can starving yourself and taking weight
loss pills.
Um,
it's definitely
probably should be addressed at some point.
Understatement.
Oh look who's back with Gruesbeck.
Oh,
Cutie Pie.
Um,
I'm kind of glad you didn't see all this.
This guy just said a bunch of horrible stuff about a sister that she's a whore.
Well,
and she also seems like a,
a complete sociopath,
but she just kind of uses people and when she can't,
she's got a lot of shit going on it sounds like.
But this is also just like a mess,
but it's also if she has an eating disorder that's awful.
That's it.
It's like a mental illness.
Maybe she's just dizzy.
No,
sorry.
Am I fucking,
Nah,
somebody started asking.
That's hardcore cause like if you,
if it's like really,
I knew a girl who was bulimic but she was a really nice person.
She wasn't walking around with treating people like shit.
So I think that this girl had a,
everybody,
not everyone's gonna like go about it the same.
That's what I'm saying.
So maybe if she has like a full belly,
she'd still be a cut.
That is very true.
Or is she?
Yeah.
Or She's like,
I'm a fucking,
just a mess.
This is kind of like when people have addicts or whatever as the blanks and they
feel like everyone is sort of like tiptoeing around them and they're like,
this person is a fucking jerk and an asshole.
Why are we,
you know,
and I'm doing all the right things.
Like I don't understand why they are being tiptoed around and that's,
it's not fair.
Yeah.
I think all three of them,
her,
her little brother and her dad
should,
uh,
say like,
listen,
if you don't stop acting the way you're acting,
you got to move out.
Right.
Basically it,
and then when she's,
you know,
stomps around like some fucking,
Clydesdale,
I wonder if they ever had any like good times together either than when they
were like six or something.
Like have they ever like gone out to eat and I have no idea what's going on with
you.
Like why are you so angry all the time?
Or as like,
her behavior's so bad that you don't even want to be in the same room where
there,
but I heard what you said that he should move out.
That's basically the best solution.
I think it's just good.
I think she's watching too many of those fucking shows where,
you know,
she thinks she's got to have some fucking certain kinds of shoes and that type
of shit.
Or Dad's a teacher,
they're living in this small ass apartment and,
uh,
I think she wants the finer things in life and she's going to get it however she
needs to get it.
So right now she's like,
all right,
I want to get all skinny and I'm going to fucking Bang my way to some weed,
the nice car.
And I think you've got a full on sociopath on your hands.
That's what I think.
And uh,
I think you guys need to gang up against her,
telling him fucking get her shit together that she has to move out.
And if your dad is,
can't get past the fact that that's the apple of our eye and he doesn't want to
do anything,
then you got to choose yourself and I would move the fuck out.
That's it.
All right.
Awful laugh.
Oh my God.
And he'll,
we,
why are you saying that she's a sociopath?
I'm just curious.
Um,
because she treats her dad's like,
Shit.
She fucking,
uh,
uses.
This is his description.
Wow.
She uses people and when she can't get anything from them,
she completely discard them,
which means she has no use for them,
but they're like,
they're like a light bulb that burned out.
All right.
I understand what this card means.
Sorry,
I just fed.
Geez.
All right.
You know what?
I deserve that.
Alright.
Awful laugh.
Hey,
Mister Bill,
birth canal.
They always did.
They try to come up with clever ways to,
uh,
with my name.
I say,
hey,
build ginger.
Had men said a gingerbread man.
That's good.
It's decent,
right?
That's all right.
Okay.
All right.
I need the brilliant wisdom that only a middle aged,
balding redhead could give you.
That this is how they do it.
They compliment and they slapped me around a little bit.
Uh,
I'm dating a lady who couldn't win a Hooters model contest.
Wow.
She can win a Hooters model contest.
Why that girl in a Paris and put her on the runway at Chanel?
Sorry
guys.
Hey,
what do you guys hate it when we say you're pretty?
No,
no.
It's not that.
It's this thing that is supposed to be like this fucking ultimate compliment.
Then she can win a modeling contest at Hooters.
I'm any other woman who was,
and this is nothing against Hooter's actually because I have all the alligator
arm at shit on odors,
but I'm saying like it's just funny to me what men or young guys consider a
compliment.
She could win a full game.
Hooters Ma,
I'm sorry if there's any girl that work at Hooters.
I fucking love Hooters and the girls are super smooth dough like Hooters and
it's all fake.
It's suited.
You're insulted by it.
I'm not.
It's,
I think it's funny the way he described her as saying she could win a Hooters.
My,
there's something really funny about that.
There was something funny about that,
but I'll tell you this stuff
you're thinking about.
You got to go on the road with me though,
Nigga.
Okay.
You got to go on the road.
You've got to understand,
you know when you live in the middle of fucking nowhere,
you know and you get big deals.
You go down to the fucking cracker barrel and you and you get down,
you get,
you get down to one little golf pig and that means you're a genius
that's out there.
Nia out there.
I'm being classes by laughing at that description because he can't just say she
died.
This girl is really beautiful because he goes on.
I'm actually funny,
intelligent level headed and as a smoker that's,
those are wonderful things,
but like the Hooters model contest,
first of all,
I didn't know that they had model contests.
Let's you mean that she could get a job at Hooters because I'm going to kind of
get a word in there.
I was actually,
I was being a dick.
Oh,
I'm joking around.
I love cracker barrel and I love when I fucking get down to the one little golf
spike.
It makes me feel like I am intelligent.
They've got that little game.
If you haven't been to cracker barrel and a million,
you shouldn't cause they said that racist shit a long time ago and I portray our
relationship every time I go there and get their rigs.
All right.
She's funny,
intelligent level headed and as a smoking hot body m an epic chest we meet with,
that's where the quitters part comes in.
She's got a great pocket wreck and that motor is a model.
God.
All right.
I'm sorry.
What should shooter you said the Applebee's fucking
like a bring chicken.
Incredibly subpar login restaurant chain with the most basic and require realize
what a snob you sound like to be sitting here in Paris.
Shit.
Nine hoarders.
Mama's l.
Absolutely.
I love it.
I love their popcorn shrimp.
You see down here.
Don't ever forget that.
Don't ever fucking forget that.
I don't give a fuck where you're at or what you're doing at the end of the day.
You like Hooters,
lemon popcorn,
shrimp,
the lemon pepper wings and the Buffalo Popcorn shrimp.
That shit is amazing.
And they have really big drinks.
It could be a little stronger though,
at least in the Hollywood one.
But uh,
no I don't.
I really don't have a problem.
I just saw the final 10 years of your life.
You've just an absolute lush sitting next to a pool.
Why isn't this fucking it?
Bigger eating fucking lemon chicken waste.
I would never have a Martini at Hooters.
I mean Margarita,
maybe
that's a kind of place you get a fireball shot.
You know what,
Nia,
you really suck gross right now.
This is my fault anyway.
Let's don't it my fault.
Oh,
there are lots of personality.
Shut up.
I'm reading this.
Why would I complain you as well?
Because you're a guy and say you have to complain about something because
I feel like putting a bullet in my head,
it sounds like
when we were at dinner at Hooters,
I assume she lasts as loud and as awful as she can.
I can see all the shot tables in my peripheral vision and hear the baby's nearby
began to violently weep.
Okay,
now you're being hyperbolic.
Uh,
when,
whenever she labs,
I do my best to stare at her rack and appreciate her until the storm is over.
This is actually kind of funny.
This girl has practically wife material with every lap.
I lose the will to live.
I'm a 26 year old male with options,
right?
You know what?
He's such an asshole.
You just shit all over the gun.
This is good.
You bounce it out.
Nothing.
That guy said,
that whole fucking hyperbole thing.
If some woman wrote that like a coyote and trash compactor and like the baby's
crying around there,
you would have laughed.
Oh my God,
this girl is hilarious.
But if a guy does it there,
there are a fucking asshole.
Let me finish this out.
I got your buddy.
Here we go.
This girl is practically wife,
26 year old male with options.
He does have options and what's Facebook now the world is his option.
Oh,
grandpa.
Uh,
I'm sorry.
What is it?
Instagram.
Is it a meme?
Is that how you meet somebody?
No
Pussy meme.
But realistically,
I don't know if I have the potential to top this girl.
Uh,
do you sell yourself short?
What do I do?
Do I suck it up and look past it or do I put on a,
or do I put on the breakup suit and dump her moments before leaping out of the
car?
Your advice and possibly the lovely Nias would be wonderful.
As calls you the lovely Nia and you're shitting on him.
I'm sure I speak for many when I say Yah.
Okay.
Sincerely possible suicide victim.
All right dude,
you don't love this girl enough to look past or laugh cause I really think if
you really loved her,
the fact that she had that crazy laugh,
you would,
they would actually,
in some weird way you find it adorable.
Uh,
I think she's just tired.
I think she's hot.
I think you have a little bit of low self esteem where you see,
you're looking at your age,
like what you,
what are you,
what are you going to fucking eggs and you,
you don't,
all right.
You're a guy.
You're young forever.
You know your biological clock isn't ticking.
You know,
I just say this shit just to get you going.
All right.
Yeah.
26 year old like,
yeah,
you got all the options in the world.
She's fucking smoking hard,
right?
Banger one more time and then fucking dumper.
Right.
Sorry.
I'm fucking with him.
Just,
just get out of it.
Just get out of the relationship and uh,
and that's the thing though,
but don't tell her why.
Don't say because you're fucking laugh.
Well she can't do any of our laugh Nia.
I know.
No bad.
Actually it's,
you go man for them both because like I'm trying to,
I was just trying to put myself in the situation like I,
you know,
being crazy about you and if you'd just had like the worst laugh like yeah,
like who do we know?
Somebody that has a lap like that that's like kind of like has like a honking
and they'll laugh and it's,
and it's funny,
but I'm sure the first time the person he's with heard it,
she was like,
Whoa,
okay.
But the thing is a person who laughs like that other,
you laugh at them for their laugh,
they laugh even more.
Everybody laughs at them and it becomes like a,
like that girl,
if you love them,
you love them.
Oh my God,
I want to
really that bad.
Like is it,
which,
I'm not going to say the name,
but I used to have somebody,
a one of my agents,
that's what I was just talking about.
One of my agents that I loved him to death and actually loved his laugh,
especially because you could hear it and when he was in the crowd and I knew
that he thought the joke was funny and he had seen a bunch of comedy.
So to really get him to laugh was an amazing thing here.
Right now.
I remember being onstage at Caroline's and I'm killing for a half an hour.
And I,
and I knew he was in the crowd,
but I'm not thinking that.
I'm just thinking of doing my shit.
And about a half hour in,
I tried this new bit and I ripped this thing in a fucking killed in the middle
of that.
I hear in the back of the club,
you just hear
the hog.
Yeah.
But I have,
I'm not even doing the thing.
Yeah.
And uh,
yeah.
And He,
and he hated his laugh too.
He hated his laugh and he's just like,
I know.
That's how I left on flower,
blah,
uh,
fucking sweet out of a gun.
Great.
We're talking about a leg is dead.
Uh,
I got a to spark your stuff is this internet here stinks and this is going to
take me forever to upload this.
Did I really go an hour and a half?
Fuck,
uh,
really quickly near,
sorry.
Sorry for the,
uh,
getting you there too early to the tennis match.
You're hung in there like a fucking champ.
Did you talk about that?
Yeah,
I basically said that I had a great fucking time,
but,
but the crowd is not my crowd.
I mean,
let's kill,
let's kill the hood.
The hood is crowd.
Isn't your crowd either?
Nia?
I love the Hooters.
The restaurant.
All right.
I like the Hooters restaurant.
It's a weird one because you've got all this shit and then you got the rogue
person that's like,
come on Casey.
Like we,
when we are Australia,
you'd have people get mad.
They get mad at somebody,
yell,
scream out because it's like they have to concentrate.
Can I give you what to do that on the golf field?
I feel like it's a similar thing,
right?
Literally what I just said.
Okay.
It's a golf course.
Yeah.
So it's weird,
but there's this aggression to it as well.
It's a golf course,
not a golf field.
Did I say for Garfield Golf Stadium when you were at the golf arena?
All right.
I am,
I have to wrap this up because this thing's going to take forever to load.
All right?
Okay.
All right.
That's just once again,
thank you for everybody for listening.
Thanks for writing in all of that shit.
I got the,
uh,
I got my tour coming up.
Um,
when I get back,
I can't wait to do stand up.
Um,
I miss it,
man.
I fucking miss it.
Um,
let me read off the dates here.
Uh,
I will be in Portland,
Oregon.
Fucking love that.
I never even heard that Portland,
Oregon.
There you haven't been,
you haven't been to Portland.
No.
I would love to know.
I've spent enough time with you.
I've spent enough time with him.
[inaudible] Portland,
Oregon.
This,
listen,
I'm telling you some of the best fucking food,
Portland and Seattle.
Unbelievably beautiful.
Fucking awesome.
Oh,
cool.
As people.
It's fucking unbelievable.
Sacramento,
California.
I'm going next June 19th,
the capitol.
June 19th.
I don't know shit about Sacramento other than I used to say in this horrific
comedy club condo across from the punchline out there.
And the only thing I could do is walk to this dirty Mcdonald's where there was
this crack head.
So I am holding out Sacramento was a bunch of really rich republican white
people.
Um,
not the part I was staying in.
Wow.
Um,
Reno,
bizarre guitar and gunshot.
Definitely going to swing by there.
Santa Rosa never been there.
I'm playing that on June 21st June 22nd.
I'm in San Jose.
I've been there a bunch of times.
I love that fucking town.
Fresno.
Never been to Fresno.
One of the thing I've seen,
there's about gang activity and they have,
uh,
they have a good,
they have good football team.
Well they did.
I don't know.
If not,
they've been doing the last couple of years.
Uh,
then I'm in Bakersfield,
California.
Then highly California.
I don't know why.
It just sounds like,
yeah,
Buddy Baker.
Wasn't that Brewster Baker?
Kenny Rogers.
That's why Bruce to Baker.
Do you remember that show?
Nope.
Okay.
Then I'm in Las Vegas on the 26th,
the Mirage,
and then I'm in Tucson,
Arizona.
I've talked and coolest that tour all down the west coast.
And uh,
Arlene Schnitzer,
the Arlene Schnitzer concert hall.
Who is that?
Somebody who died but accomplished,
accomplished enough in life.
Sorry.
That we went on and how you are and you turned to mean you're like a woman and
vented shut up bebe.
Oh,
yeah,
yeah.
We'll,
we'll tell that next time.
Okay.
That sounds good.
No,
no,
I,
okay.
Clico was that what it is?
It's CLICO.
Yeah,
she wanted,
my wife is such a drunk.
She wanted to say,
she wanted to take a tour of how they make champagne.
So we get an we fucking drive out to the countryside and uh,
went to this really cool ass town.
I forget what it was called.
And we took a tour of this thing and,
uh,
I hate champagne.
Gives me a brutal hangover.
I don't like sweet shit.
Right?
Um,
so they used to have these minds where they dug for chalk and you went down like
these are shut up.
They went down these 80 fucking I do,
I get through.
This is such a cool fucking story.
I'll tell it on Thursday.
Anyways,
long story short,
a guy actually came up with the shit and then he died at 27,
and then,
uh,
she was the love of his life.
[inaudible] vote means the widow.
And that was the last name.
She kept the last name of her husband that died and she took over this
champagne,
but she fucking perfected it and took it to the next level and an event in a way
to get that sediment out of it to make it clear as shit.
Um,
and she kinda did some fucking scumbag shit though,
that all great companies have to do if they're going to go internationally.
When Napoleon lost to the Russians,
okay.
French guy,
they lost to the Russians and the Russians wanted to celebrate.
She fucking sent them over champagne to the,
to the people that fucking just beat her called countries.
And it's fucking horrific.
But I'll tell you right now.
Yeah.
But you know every God,
yeah,
she has,
she behaved like a bank does.
They got money on both horses.
Whoever wins,
they still,
and like don king,
but at a fucking corporate level.
All right,
I'm done.
Go Fuck Yourself.
So I'll talk to you on Thursday.
I'll check in.
No,
and yeah.